we're looking at one of the single
canvases from a series of canvases of
the campbell soup cans by andy warhol
from 1962 at the museum of modern art
and one of the really important
questions that comes up about especially
modern art is well why is this art when
you ask me that a bunch of things kind
of surface in my brain it does evoke
something in me so i'm inclined to say
yes but then there's a bunch of other
things that say well if i didn't see
this in a museum and if i just saw this
in the marketing department of campbell
soup would you be viewing it differently
because it's advertising then yes but in
the context of the museum or in the
context of andy warhol studio it's not
quite advertising right even if it's the
exact same thing yeah and the idea here
is by putting it in the museum it's
saying look at this in a different way
well that's right it really does
relocate it it does change the meaning
it does transform it and that's really
one of the central ideas of modern art
is that you can take something that's
not necessarily based in technical skill
because i don't think you would say that
this is beautifully rendered right but
it relocates it and makes us think about
it in a different way and so i guess he
would get credit for taking something
that was very almost mundane something
you see on everyone in everyone's
cupboard and making it a focal point
like you should pay attention to this
thing i think that's exactly right and i
think that he's doing it about a subject
that was about as low a subject as one
could go i mean cheap advertising art
was something that was so far away from
fine art from the great masters and then
to focus on something as lowly as a can
of soup and and cream of chicken no less
right and but you know a lot of it is
if you did it 50 years earlier people
thought this guy's a quack and if he did
it now they'd think he's just derivative
and
right i mean it was really just that
that time
where people happened to think this was
art well i think that that's right in
1962 what warhol is doing is he's saying
what is it about our culture that is
really authentic and important and it
was about mass production it was about
factory he in a sense said let's not be
looking at nature as if we were still an
agrarian culture we're now an industrial
culture what is the stuff of our visual
world now i think i'm 80 there i
remember in college there was a like a
little student-run art exhibit and as a
prank a student actually put a little
podium there and put his lunch tray he
put a little placard next to it you know
lunch tray on saturday or something with
what he called it so he did it as a
prank and never thought it was really
funny but to some degree it's kind of
sounding like maybe what he did was art
well i think that's why it was funny
because it was so close right and to
some degree when someone took a lunch
tray and gave it the proper lighting and
gave it a podium to look at it and wrote
a whole description about it i did view
the lunch tray in a different way i mean
that is it's kind of the same idea
something that's like such a mundane
thing but you use it every day i mean
what what would you say to that was was
that a prank or was that art well i
think it is a prank but it's also very
close to some important art that had
been made earlier in the century he had
license to do that because of somebody
named marcel duchamp in fact warhol had
in a sense the same kind of license to
not focus on the making of something not
focus on the brush work not focus on the
composition not focus on the color
but focus on the refocusing of ideas and
the reason why we talk about warhol or
duchamp or any of these people is that
as you said it's not like they did
something technically profound obviously
campbell soups marketing department had
already done something as equally as as
profound it's more that they were the
people who looked at the world in a
slightly different way and and
highlighted that well i think that
that's right but warhol is also very
consciously
working towards asking the same
questions that the prankster at your
school was asking he's saying
can this be art and in fact he's really
pushing it look at the painting closely
for a moment this is one of the last
paintings that he's actually painted
he's really defined the calligraphy of
the campbells he's really surrendered
the reflection of the tin at the top but
then he stopped and he said i don't want
to paint the floor to leaves you see
those little those little florida leaves
down at the bottom i don't want to paint
those so we actually had a little rubber
stamp made of them and actually sort of
placed them down mechanically what does
that mean for an artist then to say i
don't even want to bother to paint these
i'm just going to find a mechanical
process to make this easier warhol is
doing something i think which is
important which is reflecting the way
that we manufacture the way that we
construct our world think about the
things that we surround ourselves with
almost everything was made in a factory
almost nothing is singular in the world
anymore it's not a world that we would
normally find beautiful i know sometimes
i feel and correct me if i'm wrong that
a decision was made that warhol was
interesting or great and then
people will interpret his stuff to
justify his greatness that oh look he
used a printer instead of drawing it
which shows that he was reflecting the
you know industrial or whatever but then
if he'd done the other way if he had
hand drawn it or hand drawn it with his
elbow or you know or denzel or finger
painted it or something oh isn't this
tremendous because we normally would see
this thing printed by a machine and now
he did it with his hands how much do you
think that is the case or or am i just
being cynical well i know i think that
i think that there's value in a certain
degree of cynicism and i think that in
some ways what we're really talking
about here is what does it mean to be an
avant-garde artist what does it mean to
sort of change the language of art and
to try to find ways that art relates to
our historical moment in some really
sort of direct and authentic way and
maybe it's easy for me to say this
because you know i remember looking at
this when i was you know when i took
fifth grade art class andy warhol and
all of that and so now it seems almost
not
that unique but in 62 what i'm hearing
is that warhol was really noteworthy
because he really did push people's
thinking i think that warhol was looking
for in 1962 a kind of subject matter
that was completely outside of the scope
that we could consider fine art one of
his contemporaries roy lichtenstein was
asked what pop art was and he said well
we were looking for a subject matter
that was so despicable that was so low
that nobody could possibly believe that
it was really art and i think you're
right i think now we look at it and it's
so much a part of our visual culture
that you know we immediately accept it
but i think it's really interesting to
retrieve just how shocking and radical
that was this is fascinating it seems
like there's a lot of potential there
that stuff that it's kind of pseudo art
made for other purposes for commercial
purposes but if you kind of shine a
light on it
in the way that a light has been shown
on this it it does
in your mind would that cross the
barrier into being art
well i think that you know you mentioned
before that if somebody was doing this
now it would feel really derivative
right and i think that that's right i
think it underscores just how hard it is
to find in our culture now ways of
making us see the world in new ways yeah
fascinating
you